vous vous dites que tout travail est une
forme d'altruisme c'est pas du tout ce
que l'on entend en ce moment comment
arriver arriverez-vous à convaincre les
gens que avocat fiscaliste ou
publicitaire c'est une forme d'altruisme
j'ai essayé d'insister sur le fait qu'
on comprend prenons mal le travail en
france vous savez ya cette fameuse
étymologique et probablement faux seins
mais celle des teams logique
traditionnelle letra des halles ce
serait le tripalium le trip à
l'instrument de torture donc on n'est
pas tout à fait sûr ça soit la vraie
étymologiquement sont elles qui est
accepté et donc on voit très bien qu'il
ya cette idée du travail comme étant
fondamentalement selon l'omi public vous
savez d'adam et eve chassés du paradis
le travail c'est fondamentalement une
punition moi j'essayais juste d'insister
sur le fait qu'il y avait aussi une
façon beaucoup plus positive alors c'est
peut-être la façon dont les protestants
comprennent le travail beaucoup plus
facilement parce que ça fait partie de
cette technique particulière comme l'a
signalé max weber mais le travail il est
aussi réalisation de soi il est
réalisation de ce on est en effet dans
la société avant le coronavirus vous
souvenez on a vu tout ce débat autour
des entreprises admission et je crois
que c'était très intéressant de voir que
le débat actuel finalement recentre la
chose autour de la question de l'utilité
qu'on a chacun dans nos travailleurs
c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup dans
beaucoup de grandes entreprises qu'on
appelle des bullshit job on se rend
compte que le monde serait évidemment
pareil si on n'était pas là et
probablement qu'on a été uniquement
notre job est une forme de création de
la terrible mécanique du rau cratique ça
c'est possible aussi
mais ce sont des rires des cas
particuliers un petit peu comme le cas
des exploitations lequel la domination
le cas des travailleurs des patrons
souhaité ce sont des cas particuliers
moi je trouve dommage c'est finalement
qui n'inscrit pas en fait j'essaie
plutôt de deux nuances et en fait un
rapprochement on a ra d'habitude sur le
sur le travail on c'est dommage de ne
pas constater qu' il y à des cas
extrêmes et c'est pas parce qu'il ya des
gens qui se tue en voiture qu'on va pas
conduire la même façon c'est pas parce
que de temps en temps
parfois malheureusement le travail c'est
une exploitation oui c'est vrai que le
travail et les effets domination parfois
mais c'est dommage on ne le comprend
que comme ça
[Musique]